vatican says pope francis is doing well
after intestinal surgery on yesterday
it was a planned procedure we should say
for francis who
is 84 years old chris libsay is outside
the hospital in rome where the pope is
recovering
chris it's good to hear he's recovering
84 is always dicey when you go into
surgery this is good news
yeah that's right gail the vatican says
pope francis is now breathing on his own
after having part of his colon removed
due to diverticulitis that's a common
inflammation
among the elderly he's now staying right
behind me on the top floor of the
gemelli hospital
in the same suite of rooms where pope
john paul ii stayed
several times during his pontificate
francis's operation came just hours
after he delivered his regular sunday
angelus from his window overlooking
saint peter's square
where he made no mention of the
procedure rather he announced he'd be
traveling to hungary and slovakia in
september
and he's had a busy week he met with the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
on monday
the iraqi prime minister on friday and
even held an
all-day prayer service for lebanon on
thursday
now this is the very first time the 84
year old pontiff
has been hospitalized since becoming
pope back in 2013. the vatican says it
should take about seven
days for him to recover gail all right
chris livesay reporting from rome we
thank you